This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。“有据可查”。2%。这是面对有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是数字 2. 可以在 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听 Look Back at it 播客。从 1979 年开始，这对我和来说是个重要时刻。84 年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯（Alex English）。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊 80 年代。84 年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
欢迎在 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听 Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听 Learn the Hard Way，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行一些在任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套或多层盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
欢迎在 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听 Learn the Hard Way。2023 年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测报告。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。欢迎在 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《深陷爱河》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode, as we have, of course, as we have,
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。请收听 The Girlfriends。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你们能来到这里，收听又一期节目，就像我们一直以来那样，就像我们一直以来
course break down the psychology of our 20s. If you can't already hear it, surprise, surprised, I am once again ill. I have a pretty nasty like cold slash chest infection. So I really apologize for my voice being very, very nasally. I just got back from a lot of travel like three weeks in the United States and then traveling for a family birthday. It's obviously taken a little bit of a toll, but I'm on the up and up. I'm feeling better. I just want to say sorry slash acknowledge that my voice is going to sound perhaps a little bit nasally in this episode. Hopefully by next Tuesday, I'm fully mended and you guys don't have to bear with the sick voice for any much longer. But I really didn't want to skip this episode. I didn't want to
当然，我们要剖析二十多岁时的心理。如果你还听不出来的话，惊不惊喜，意不意外，我又双叒生病了。我得了挺严重的类似感冒加胸部感染的病。所以我的声音听起来非常非常重鼻音，我真的非常抱歉。我刚结束长途旅行，在美国呆了大约三个星期，然后又为了参加一个家庭生日而到处奔波。这显然对我的身体造成了一点影响，但我正在康复中。我感觉好多了。我只是想道个歉/说明一下，在这期节目中我的声音听起来可能会有点鼻音。希望到下周二时我能完全康复，大家就不用再忍受我这生病的声音太久了。但我真的不想跳过这期节目，我不想
skip this Friday's topic because we're talking about something I think is very near and dear to a lot of 20-something-year-olds. Navigating our careers in our 20s is tough. There are a lot of dead ends, a lot of moments where we feel incapable, we feel like we're falling behind, we can't get the promotion we want, let alone the job. And the thing that always makes it worse is seeing someone who is seemingly not struggling at all. They have the dream job, they have the career progression, the success, the accolades.
跳过这个周五的话题，因为我们今天要聊的事情，我认为对于许多二十多岁的人来说是非常感同身受的。在二十多岁时摸索我们的职业生涯是艰难的。有许多死胡同，有许多时刻我们觉得自己无能为力，觉得自己正在掉队，我们得不到想要的晋升，更不用说工作了。而总是让情况变得更糟的是，看到某人似乎完全没有在挣扎。他们拥有梦想的工作、职业发展、成功和荣誉。
maybe it's not even someone that you know. It could be a celebrity, an influencer, someone you follow online. Regardless, we can't help but look at all that they have and feel not just envious, but pretty terrible about ourselves. It also probably elicits some thoughts like, why not me? Like, this is so unfair. They don't even deserve it. And with those thoughts comes a lot of shame because we have been taught from a lot of. an early age, that jealousy is a so-called ugly emotion, and we should just be happy for others
也许这甚至都不是你认识的人。可能是一个名人、一个网红、一个你在网上关注的人。无论如何，我们情不自禁地看着他们拥有的一切，不仅感到嫉妒，而且对自己的现状感到非常糟糕。这大概也会引发一些想法，比如：为什么不是我？这太不公平了。他们甚至都不配。伴随着这些想法，会产生很多羞耻感，因为我们从小就被灌输一种观念，即嫉妒是一种所谓的丑陋情绪，我们应该为别人感到高兴
rather than bitter. I think anyone who has experienced career jealousy or jealousy of any form knows that that is not always a choice. And that is a very, very lovely sentiment to be happy for everyone at all times. But jealousy is just a part of life. It's hard and it's sometimes miserable, but it's also not an emotion that we are going to let define us. We want to form a healthier relationship with it, especially in our 20s and especially when it comes to our professional lives. So today we are talking career jealousy in our 20s, why it happens, what it feels like, and most importantly, how to ensure it doesn't weigh you down because we have so much more to worry about in this life, what other people may or may not be doing or may or may not have
而不是心怀苦涩。我想任何经历过职业嫉妒或任何形式嫉妒的人都知道，这并不总是一个选择。为所有人在所有时刻感到高兴，这是一种非常非常美好的愿望。但嫉妒只是生活的一部分。这很难，有时也很痛苦，但它也不是一种我们要让它来定义我们的情绪。我们想要与它建立更健康的联系，尤其是在我们的二十多岁，尤其是当它涉及到我们的职业生活时。所以今天我们来聊聊二十多岁时的职业嫉妒，它为什么会发生，感觉如何，最重要的是，如何确保它不会成为你的负担，因为在这生活中我们还有更多需要担心的事，别人可能在做什么、可能没做什么，或者可能拥有什么、可能没有拥有什么
should not be added to that list. I really want to take us through, of course, the psychology of this experience. And I want to talk about my own personal struggle with this because I'm going to be super vulnerable. This is something that, especially when I was in my early 20s, I think, ended up hurting a lot of my relationships that I was quite jealous and I felt quite insecure about where I was heading from those experiences. I hope, and I do believe I've learned a lot. So hopefully you can learn from my mistakes and maybe take something from my wisdom. But I also want to talk about how this shows up between siblings,
不应该被加入那个清单。当然，我非常想带大家了解这种经历背后的心理学。我想谈谈我自己在这方面的切身体会，因为我将非常坦诚。这是这样一件事，尤其是在我二十岁出头的时候，我认为它最终伤害了我很多关系，当时我相当嫉妒，而且对那些经历带给我的前路感到相当没有安全感。我希望，我也坚信我已经学到了很多。所以希望你们能从我的错误中吸取教训，或许能从我的智慧中汲取一些东西。但我也想谈谈这种情绪是如何在兄弟姐妹之间表现出来的，
between even our bestest of friends, the role of self-esteem, culture, even social media influences. There is a lot packed into this episode today. Hopefully it is an entire guidebook if you are struggling with this in your life right now. I hope you know you're not alone. I hope you leave this episode not feeling too terrible about yourself, but also knowing how to manage this very complicated feeling. Without further ado, let us get into the psychology of career jealousy.
甚至在我们最好的朋友之间，自尊、文化、甚至社交媒体网红所扮演的角色。今天这期节目内容非常丰富。如果你目前的生活正在为此苦恼，希望它能成为一本完整的指南。我希望你知道你并不孤单。我希望你听完这期节目后，不会对自己的现状感到太糟糕，同时也知道如何管理这种非常复杂的情感。废话不多说，让我们进入职业嫉妒的心理学。
So what is professional or career jealousy? Let's start with a nice, good old-fashioned explanation. It's pretty simple. Career jealousy describes feeling envious, almost exclusively. towards someone's professional life compared to your own and seeing something in their life or professional success that you want or maybe even feel that you deserve. Let's be super, super clear here. It is so much more common than you think. Jealousy in general is a very universal human emotion, of course. About 75% of people polled in a recent piece of research reported that they experienced
那么什么是专业嫉妒或职业嫉妒呢？让我们从一个美好的、老式的解释开始。这其实很简单。职业嫉妒描述的是一种羡慕心理，几乎是专属于
jealousy at least once last year. And career jealousy is in fact one of the top ways that we experience this feeling after firstly material jealousy and interpersonal jealousy. So feeling jealous of the relationships that someone has with someone else. Current estimates say that around 27% of people experience career jealousy in their lifetime with that typically spiking at two different points in time. The first one, of course, is our 20s, and the second one is actually in our 50s. Of course, unsurprisingly, it is exceedingly common in our 20s, as I just said. And I would even say more so now in this generation compared to those who have come before. It's common in our 20s, I think, because insecurity around just about everything is common in our 20s. It is such a general
对于别人的职业生活与你自己的相比，并且在他们的生活或职业成功中看到了你想要的，或者甚至觉得你应得的东西。让我们在这里超级、超级明确一点。这比你想象的要常见得多。当然，嫉妒总的来说是一种非常普遍的人类情感。在最近的一项研究中，大约 75% 的受访者表示他们经历过
experience that we are all going to have to feel as if we have absolutely no clue what we're doing in almost all areas of our life. And so when we see someone who apparently does know what they're doing, it can be shocking and immediately elicited a sense of panic. Like, wait, hold up a second. Is it just me who's falling behind? Is there something I'm doing wrong? Is there something that no one is telling me that these people have somehow figured out? Now, if those, thoughts aren't deliberately shut down pretty quickly, this can become a chronic thought pattern for us and that obviously takes a massive toll in our self-esteem. It can also have us looking around for more evidence that we are indeed failures. So we start selectively searching or
嫉妒，去年至少有一次。而职业嫉妒实际上是我们体验这种感觉的主要方式之一，仅次于物质嫉妒和人际嫉妒。也就是说，嫉妒别人与某人的关系。目前的估计表明，大约 27% 的人在其一生中经历过职业嫉妒，这种情况通常在两个不同的时间点达到顶峰。第一个，当然是我们的二十多岁，第二个其实是在我们的五十多岁。当然，不出所料，正如我刚才所说，这在我们的二十多岁极其常见。而且我甚至可以说，与前辈相比，这一代人更是如此。我认为这在我们的二十多岁很常见，因为对几乎所有事情的不安全感在我们的二十多岁都很常见。这是一种非常普遍的
seeking out further examples of what we have now already tend to believe about ourselves, that we're behind, that we don't know what we're doing, that we are the only ones. It's a very nasty trick that our mind plays on us. You probably know it by the term confirmation bias. The tendency to search for, interpret, favor, and recall information in a way that confirms our prior beliefs or values, including the mean beliefs that we have about ourselves that are just in no way helpful. Thinking of yourself as a failure is in no way. helpful, but for anyone who has struggled with that, they know that that is not always the easiest thought pattern to break if it has become ingrained by repeated instances of you
体验，我们所有人都会觉得，在几乎生活的所有领域，我们完全不知道自己在做什么。所以当我们看到一个显然知道自己在做什么的人时，它可能会让人震惊，并立即引发一种恐慌感。就像，等等，等一下。难道只有我一个人在掉队吗？是我做错了什么吗？是不是有什么别人都没告诉我，而这些人却莫名其妙摸索出来了的东西？现在，如果那些想法没有被迅速、刻意地遏制住，这就会成为我们的一种慢性思维模式，这显然会对我们的自尊造成巨大的打击。它还会让我们四处寻找更多的证据来证明我们确实是失败者。所以我们开始有选择性地搜索或
thinking that that is the case. That kind of also means that you stop seeing or acknowledging the people who are struggling, the people who are unsure of what they want in their careers, who are unemployed, and you only unconsciously pay attention to the people who have it all together. So you end up having this very selectively skewed vision of people in their 20s and what professional success looks like for them in general. This can also cause a lot of anger and resentment because when you feel terrible about your circumstances, there are kind of only two alternative routes for your brain to take. You can either feel bad about yourself and believe that your circumstances reflect your character and your worth, that's option one. Or you can feel angry at the world and you can
寻找更多的例子，来印证我们现在已经倾向于相信的关于我们自己的事：我们落后了，我们不知道自己在做什么，我们是唯一这样的人。这是我们的大脑对我们玩的一个非常恶劣的把腿。你可能通过“确认偏差”这个词了解它。这种倾向会以某种方式搜索、解释、偏爱和回忆信息，从而证实我们先前持有的信念或价值观，包括我们对自己所抱有的刻薄信念，而这些信念对我们毫无益处。认为自己是个失败者绝对没有任何
feel angry at other people and say, well, you obviously don't deserve this. This is unfair. Like I said, it's very, very nasty and it's often subconscious or unconscious. Now, career jealousy is not a one-dimensional thing. It's not just one big bucket of fear, insecurity and frustration. I've come to realize that I think there are actually three forms of career jealousy. Firstly, I think we can be jealous towards someone just for having a job. You know, like I said before, it's bloody tough out there. It is tough. Sometimes if you're in the trenches and one of your friends suddenly gets a great job whilst you've been working really hard and looking for way longer, it's very difficult not to resent them and resent your circumstances. Secondly, we can feel professional jealousy
好处，但对于任何与这种想法作斗争过的人来说，他们都知道，如果这种想法已经通过你一再认为事实确实如此的经历根深蒂固，那么要打破这种思维模式并不总是最容易的。这也意味着你不再看到或承认那些正在挣扎的人，那些对自己的职业生涯感到迷茫的人，那些失业的人，而你在潜意识里只会关注那些把一切都处理得井井有条的人。所以你最终会对二十多岁的人以及他们的整体职业成功应该是什么样子，产生一种非常具有选择性的歪曲看法。这也会引起很多愤怒和怨恨，因为当你对自己的现状感到糟糕时，你的大脑其实只有两条备选路线可走。要么你对自我感觉糟糕，并认为你的现状反映了你的品格和价值，这是第一种选择。要么你可以对世界感到愤怒，你可以
over someone else's sense of purpose. So it's not just that they have a job or they have a career, but they have something that they really care about. And who amongst us doesn't want that? Having a purpose when it comes to our profession, I think turns a job into a career. Like a job is something that you can just do because it makes money. A career, and even bigger than that, a mission is something that you are personally invested in.
对其他人感到愤怒，并说，你显然不配拥有这个。这太不公平了。就像我说的，这非常非常恶劣，而且通常是潜意识或无意识的。现在，职业嫉妒并不是一个单一维度的东西。它不仅仅是一大堆恐惧、不安全感和挫折感。我渐渐意识到，我认为职业嫉妒其实有三种形式。首先，我认为我们可能会因为别人有工作而嫉妒某人。你知道的，就像我之前说的，外面竞争太残酷了。真的很残酷。有时如果你身处水深火热之中，而你的一个朋友突然找到了一份好工作，而你却一直在努力工作并找了更长的时间，你很难不怨恨他们和你的处境。其次，我们可以对别人的使命感产生职业嫉妒
and there's like a fire in your belly. We know from repeated psychology studies in this area that this sense of purpose is linked to increased life satisfaction and sometimes even life expectancy. So when you're in your 20s and it seems like everyone is slowly figuring out what they want to do and you haven't figured it out yet, you can feel really, really envious. I will say, I think the older we get, the more we realize that our profession or our career, is not our primary sense of purpose in life. It's not the sole thing that can imbue your life with a sense of meaning.
。所以不仅仅是因为他们有一份工作或一个职业，而是因为他们有真正关心的事情。我们当中谁不想要这个呢？当涉及到我们的职业时，拥有一个目标，我认为能把一份工作变成一项事业。就像工作可以只是你为了赚钱而做的事情。而一份事业，甚至比这更伟大的使命，是你个人投入其中的事情，
So I know those statistics I just gave or like those findings seem kind of scary. Like, oh my God, are you telling me if I don't find my purpose? I'm going to die sooner. No, no, absolutely not. You have a lot of time to find your purpose. It's more that I think people struggle with thinking it's only going to come from a job. The people who are truly happy realize that it comes from more than just that. but sometimes career can fulfill that need pretty early on in our lives before we've learned that
心中燃起了一团火。我们从该领域反复进行的心理学研究中得知，这种使命感与提高的生活满意度甚至有时与预期寿命息息相关。所以，当你二十多岁的时候，似乎每个人都在慢慢弄清楚自己想做什么，而你还没弄清楚，你就会感到非常非常嫉妒。我得说，我认为我们年纪越大，就越意识到我们的职业或事业并不是我们生命中主要的使命感。它不是唯一能为你的生活注入意义感的东西。
lesson. Okay, finally, the final kind of bucket of envy is envy towards someone's progress, success and the material things that they have been rewarded with. You know the friend or the person online who you see and they are going on these amazing trips and they are suddenly buying nice clothes, nice dinners, winning awards. They've been promoted like three times before 20, they've bought a house from their job. These situations of material success, objective material wealth, can serve as a very stark and a very tangible reminder of what we don't have. Maybe I'm going to say this, of what we don't have yet.
所以我知道我刚刚给出的那些统计数据或者说那些发现听起来有点吓人。就像，哦天哪，你是说如果我找不到我的使命，我会死得更快吗？不，不，绝对不是。你有很长的时间去寻找你的使命。更确切地说，我认为人们纠结于认为它只会来自于一份工作。真正快乐的人意识到它不仅仅来自于此。但有时职业可以在我们学到那个教训之前，很早就满足这种需求。
That's the other cruel part of career jealousy. All we can never focus on is what we don't have right now, not what we've had in the past, not what we may have in the future. and we don't focus on what we actually don't want. You know, you might see someone who you're like immediately envious of. They're famous. They're successful. Immediately you're like, well, maybe I should be doing that.
好吧，最后，最后一种嫉妒是针对某人的进步、成功以及他们因之获得回报的物质条件的嫉妒。你知道那个你在网上看到的朋友或那个人，他们正在进行这些精彩的旅行，他们突然买了好衣服，吃了昂贵的晚餐，赢得了奖项。他们在 20 岁之前就被晋升了大约三次，他们靠工作买了一套房子。这些物质成功、客观物质财富的情况，可以作为一个非常鲜明且切实可触的提醒，提醒我们没有拥有什么。也许我要这么说，提醒我们还没有拥有什么。
What you don't think is, you know, I probably don't actually want to be famous. I probably don't want to work 100 hours a week. I probably don't want to live out of my suitcase. But it's this want what I can't have mindset. and cherry-picking all the situations and the selective parts of someone's story that make us feel miserable. Why does this happen? Because I think we can all agree that given how awful career jealousy feels, it's not something that we are voluntarily opting into. Career jealousy, I think, is on the rise for a couple of reasons. Firstly, I think the reason that we're experiencing it more is that we have just more opportunity,
这就是职业嫉妒的另一个残酷之处。我们所能关注的只是我们现在没有的东西，而不是我们过去拥有的，也不是我们未来可能拥有的。而且我们不会关注我们实际上不想要的东西。你知道，你可能会看到某人，你立刻就会嫉妒他们。他们很有名。他们很成功。你马上就会想，好吧，也许我也应该那样做。
to compare. This day and age, every single thing is public and online. There's a really fascinating research paper I found when I was researching this episode, which explored envy towards social media influences in South Korea, and it found that our level of personal jealousy increases alongside our usage of social media. Now, that might seem pretty obvious, but yeah, the more you are exposed to these perfect ideas of success that are very, very present in this generation, the more we feel lacking. There is also, you know, literally a social media for our jobs, LinkedIn. I remember writing an article when I was back in university and it was titled like, in hell they make you use LinkedIn, where I talked about how it's basically just another way to feel constantly behind.
你没有想到的是，你知道，我可能实际上并不想出名。我可能不想一周工作 100 个小时。我可能不想把家当塞在手提箱里生活。但这就是“我想要我得不到的东西”的心态，并且挑三拣四地挑选某人故事中那些让我们感到痛苦的情节和选择性部分。为什么会这样？因为我想大家都会同意，鉴于职业嫉妒的感觉有多么糟糕，这不是我们自愿选择陷入其中的。我认为，职业嫉妒正在上升，原因有几个。首先，我认为我们体验到更多的原因是，我们有更多机会
It's another example of appearances. And I think my opinion on it still stands. When all you see of people's careers is the glossy outside, not the grueling inside, it's very easy to feel like you're missing out. The other reason that we might feel jealous is that career does just make up such a big part of our identity. It is, in fact, one of what we call the big buckets of identity. So if you think about who you are, there are all these different areas where you can pour energy. into that make you feel accomplished as a person and build upon your identity.
去进行比较。在当今时代，每一件小事都是公开的，都在网上。我在研究这期节目时发现了一篇非常吸引人的研究论文，它探讨了对韩国社交媒体网红的嫉妒心理，发现我们的个人嫉妒水平随着我们对社交媒体的使用而增加。现在，这似乎很明显，但确实，你越多地接触到这一代人中非常非常普遍的这些完美成功理念，我们就越会感到自己有所欠缺。另外，（我们）甚至有一个专门针对我们工作的社交媒体——领英（LinkedIn）。我记得我在上大学时写过一篇文章，标题类似于“在人间炼狱里他们逼你用领英”，我在文中谈到它基本上只是另一种让你不断感到自己落后的方式。
So your relationships, your values, your family, your history, your career. Career is a big bucket. When something is that prominent in our lives, when you could be spending a third of your waking life in your job or working towards your career, of course your brain is going to want to make sure you're doing okay relative to others. comparison in this way acts as a form of validation that we are doing okay. Our brain naturally goes to that place. It doesn't always realize that we're going to come up short in our own minds.
这是虚有其表の另一个例子。我认为我对它的看法依然没有改变。当你对别人的职业生涯所看到的只是光鲜亮丽的外表，而不是内部的艰辛时，你很容易觉得自己错过了什么。我们可能会感到嫉妒的另一个原因是，职业确实构成了我们身份的很大一部分。事实上，它是我们所谓的身份三大桶之一。所以如果你想想你是谁，有所有这些不同的领域，你可以把精力投入其中，让你作为一个人的成就感并建立在你的身份之上。
So comparison is obviously a huge reason we experience career jealousy. There are two ways that we compare ourselves to others, upwards and downward social comparison. I'm sure you've heard about this on an episode before. Upward social comparison, you're going to look. at someone who is perhaps doing better than you and think, oh my gosh, wow, they're really amazing. I want that. Why don't I have that? You're looking upwards. You're comparing beyond what you are currently capable of. That can either elicit feelings of inspiration and motivation or despair.
所以你的人际关系、你的价值观、你的家庭、你的历史、你的职业。职业是一个大桶。当某事在我们的生活中如此突出时，当你可能会把醒着的三分之一的时间花在工作上或为你的职业奋斗时，你的大脑当然会想要确保你相对于别人过得还不错。这种比较充当了一种验证形式，证明我们过得还不错。我们的大脑自然而然地会走到那个地方。它并不总是意识到我们会在自己的心中显得矮人一截。
Then we have downward social comparison. Now downward social comparison balances out upward social comparison by allowing you to look and observe people who you think aren't doing as well as you and experience a self-esteem boost. Basically, you're saying, and it sounds really terrible, but this is genuinely what's going on in your mind, well, at least, you know, I don't have it as bad as then. So which direction of comparison you will gravitate to in this situation often depends on your personality and your current emotional state and factors like resilience and self-esteem. So for those of us with a high need for achievement and high levels of confidence, we typically gravitate towards upwards social comparison, specifically the kind
所以比较显然是我们经历职业嫉妒的一个巨大原因。我们有两种将自己与他人进行比较的方式：向上和向下社会比较。我确信你以前在某期节目中听过这个。向上社会比较，你会看。向那些可能比你过得更好的人，然后想，哦天哪，哇，他们真的很棒。我想要那个。为什么我没有那个？你在向上看。你在超越你目前能力所及的范围进行比较。这要么会激发出灵感和动力，要么会激发出绝望感。
that brings about admiration rather than feelings of insecurity. If you are someone who believes in yourself who really wants to succeed, who believes they can succeed, you are not going to be threatened by someone doing better than you, you're going to use it as an asset. Now, if you are lacking self-confidence, you feel less self-assured, maybe you've seen your self-esteem plummet recently, you are more likely to engage in downward social comparison as a deliberate form of comparison, but upward social comparison as a less deliberate form. I'm going to explain that. lots of words in that sentence. Essentially, intuitively, your brain is going to want you to compare to people who are doing so-called worse than you because it makes you feel better. But actually what
然后我们有向下社会比较。现在，向下社会比较通过让你观察和审视那些你认为不如你过得好的人并体验自尊心的提升，来平衡向上的社会比较。基本上，你在说——这听起来真的很糟糕，但这确实是你脑海中正在发生的真实想法——好吧，至少，你知道，我的情况没有他们那么糟糕。所以在这种情况下，你会倾向于哪种方向的比较，通常取决于你的性格、你当前的心理状态以及复原力和自尊等因素。所以对于我们这些对成就有着强烈需求和高度自信的人来说，我们通常倾向于向上的社会比较，特别是那种带来钦佩感而不是不安全感的那种比较。如果你是一个相信自己、非常渴望成功、相信自己能成功的人，你不会被一个比你做得更好的人威胁到，你会把它当作一种资产。现在，如果你缺乏自信，你感觉自己底气不足，也许你最近发现自己的自尊心直线下降，你更有可能将向下社会比较作为一种刻意的比较形式，而将向上社会比较作为一种不那么刻意的比较形式。我要解释一下。那句话里有很多词。本质上，直觉上，你的大脑会希望你与那些做得“比你差”的人进行比较，因为这会让你感觉更好。但实际上最终发生的是，当你进入那种比较的心态时，你就会情不自禁地慢慢转向与那些做得比你更好的人进行比较。这会让你感觉相当糟糕。现在，这可能是一个令人不安但显而易见的事实，你的职业嫉妒和比较可能也与你当前的不安全感水平有关，更具体地说，是你可能存在的对不称职的巨大恐惧。这种恐惧在个人主义社会中更为常见。所以个人主义社会是指那些我们重视个人财富、地位、物质成功、能让一个人
ends up happening is when you get into that comparison mindset, you can't help but kind of slowly move over into comparing yourself to people who are doing better than you. It's going to make you feel pretty terrible. Now, this might be an uncomfortable, but obvious truth, your career jealousy and comparison is probably also related to your current levels of insecurity, more specifically a greater fear of inadequacy that you might have. And this fear is a lot more common in individualistic societies. So individualistic societies are those in which we value personal wealth, status, material success, things that make one person.
看起来非常非常优秀的事物的社会。这与集体主义社会或集体主义文化形成对比，在集体主义文化中，一个人的成功就是大家的胜利。因此，我们更有可能花精力去看到社区的成功，去确保我们家庭的每一个成员都取得成功，而不仅仅是专注于我们自己的成功。如果你在一个个人主义社会中长大，所以，你知道，如果你在美国长大，如果你在欧洲的很多地方长大，如果你在澳大利亚、加拿大长大，很多时候，你的主要关注点以及你被教导要关注的是你与其他人相比表现得有多好，
look very, very good. This is in comparison to collectivist societies or collectivist cultures whereby the success of one person is everyone's win. So we are more likely to put effort into seeing the community succeed into making sure every member of our family is succeeding rather than just being focused on our own success. If you were raised in an individualistic society, so, you know, if you were raised in the US, if you were raised in a lot of parts of Europe, if you were raised in Australia, in Canada, a lot of the times, your main focus and what you have been taught to focus on is how well you are doing in comparison to others,
而不是整个团队表现得有多好。因此，它确实造成了对个人成功的痴迷，这意味着你社区中的其他个人、你的社交阶层中的其他人，他们的成功永远不会让你感觉良好，就像在集体主义文化中不会那样。它只会让你感觉糟糕。所以再次强调，如果你坐在那里感受着职业嫉妒，心想，
not how well the group is doing. And so it does create this obsession with personal success, meaning that other individuals in your community, in your kind of social stratosphere, their success doesn't make you ever, is never going to make you feel good the way that it wouldn't a collectivist culture. It's only going to make you feel terrible. So again, if you're sitting there feeling career jealousy thinking,
哦天哪，我再也不想这种感觉了。我对这种感觉太糟糕了。我只是想为我的朋友、我的姐姐、我的亲戚、那个人、我的同事感到高兴。通常这并不是你的错。这是你的大脑被训练成的方式。比较的另一个非常阴险的部分是我们还没有提到过的，即比较，特别是消极的向上社会比较，即使当你真的找到了成功时，它通常仍在继续。
oh my God, I don't want to feel this way anymore. I feel so bad about it. I just want to be happy for my friend, for my sister, for my relative, for that person, my colleague. Often it's not your fault. It's how your brain has been trained. The other really insidious part of comparison that we haven't mentioned is comparison, specifically negative upward social comparison, often continues even when you do find success.
所以有很多我们所谓的“成就跑步机”的例子，那些看似拥有一切的人——他们快乐、成功、充实、处于他们领域的顶峰——仍然觉得他们可以做得更好。他们仍然觉得还有更多目标要实现。所以你对自己所处的位置永远不满意。这就是为什么我们真的、真的需要在我们的生活早期、在我们二十多岁的早期、也许在你找到成功之前，就解决这种循环的比较之病。
So there are a lot of examples of what we call the achievement treadmill, where people who have seemingly done it all, they are happy, successful, fulfilled, they're at the top of their game, they still feel like they could be doing better. they still feel like there is more to achieve. And so you are never happy with where you are. This is why we really, really need to tackle this cyclical comparison sickness almost early on in our lives, early on in our 20s, perhaps before you found success.
因为否则，如果你陷入这种心态：我总是可以做得更好，我总是可以拥有更多，这也是那种会让你感到深深、深深不快乐的心态。我想在这里谈谈最后一个原因，为什么职业嫉妒可能会在上升。我们讨论了社交媒体。我们讨论了为什么有更多比较的空间。现在让我们来谈谈我们目前的职业环境或就业市场的本质。简而言之，现在的就业市场太艰难了。我知道你们很多人都在亲身经历这一点。你们一直在私信我，说，我到底哪里做错了？
Because otherwise, if you get into this mindset of, I can always be doing better, I can always have more, that is also the mindset that is going to make you deeply, deeply unhappy. I want to talk about one final reason here as to why career jealousy is probably on the rise. We talked about social media. We talked about how there's more room for comparison. Let's now just talk about the very nature of our professional environments right now or the job market. Simply put, the job market right now is so difficult. I know a lot of you have been experiencing this personally. you've been DM me saying, I just, what am I doing wrong?
也许就像你一直在找工作好几个月。没有任何进展。最终，当我们处于那种情况时，我们会开始认为是我们自己出了问题。但客观地说，我现在想告诉你，职位空缺正在减少，较少数量岗位的竞争却在加剧。人们招聘花费的时间更长，而且总体招聘人数更少。
Maybe like you've been looking for a job for months. Nothing is coming your way. Eventually, when we're in that situation, we're going to start to think that something is wrong with us. But objectively, I want to tell you right now, job vacancies are declining, there is increased competition for a smaller number of positions. People are taking longer to hire people and they are hiring less overall.
或者人工智能已经显著改变了人们正在招聘的角色类型。所有这一切都表明，对我们心理状态的一个重要影响因素将始终是我们所处的环境。而我们目前所处的环境并不特别有利于对你在职业生涯中的现状感到乐观或快乐。现在，如果我们处于这样一种情况：我们很多人都在挣扎，然后突然出现了这样一个人。他没有挣扎，（你知道的）中了大奖，把一切都搞定了。
or AI has significantly shifted what kind of roles people are hiring for. All of this to say a big contributor to our psychological state is always going to be the environment in which we are in. And the environment in which we are in right now is not particularly conducive to feeling optimistic or happy about where you're out in your career. Now, if we're in this situation where a lot of us are struggling and then suddenly there is this person who is not. who, you know, got the jackpot who had figured it all out.
我们当然会感到嫉妒。这是我们原始本能的苏醒，在说，我们怎么才能拥有那个？这很大程度上源于我们可以为更好的领土而战和偷窃的年代。我们可以为一块更好的肉、为最靠近火堆的位置而战和偷窃。如今，我们已经被社会化得意识到，你知道，你可能不能走过去和某人大打出手来抢他们的工作，
Of course we're going to feel envious. It's this primal instinct of ours kicking in, saying, how can we have that? It's very much born from the days when we could fight and steal for the better territory. We could fight and steal for the better piece of meat, for the position closest to the fire. Nowadays, we've been socialized to realize that, you know, you probably can't go up and wrestle with someone for their job,
一家四大会计师事务所。但我们大脑中那些看到自己想要的东西并立即试图弄清楚 A. 我们如何得到它，或者 B. 为什么我们如此渴望它的老旧部分，依然非常活跃。所以让我们讨论一些更深层次、未曾言说的后果，以及如何摆脱这种专业嫉妒的泥潭，并对我们现在的现状感到高兴或至少自豪的途径？所有这些以及更多内容，在这段短暂的广告之后。2%。这就是面对有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，
a big four firm. But those old parts of our brain that see something we want and immediately are trying to figure out either A, how we can get it, or B, why we want it so much, it's still very much alive. So let's discuss some of the further unspoken consequences of this, but also what is the path for getting out of this professional jealousy rut and just being happy or at least proud of where we are now? All of that and so much more after this. short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%.
我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是数字 2. 可以在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在 Look Back at it 播客中找到答案。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈 80 年代的快克（crack）毒品。需要澄清的是，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
我随时准备在白天谈论快克，但只是为了让你们所有人知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现这其中有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你完成那句话。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听 Look Back at it。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking,
特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
而我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活变得只关乎胜负。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你认为在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和使命进行真实的对话。
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
打开你免费的 iHeart Radio app。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测报告。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。
Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这还没结束。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is served in Arizona.
请在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡村女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield）。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield.
在新一季的《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不。
And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。请收听 The Girlfriends。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。所以我们在谈论职业嫉妒，是的，它会让人感到挫败，它会让人感到非常羞耻和丑陋，它会让人感觉暗地里希望别人失败，这是我们永远不想感受到的，这让我们觉得自己是个糟糕的人。还会发生什么呢？
I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So we're talking about career jealousy, and yes, it can feel like frustration, it can feel very shameful and ugly, it can feel like secretly wanting someone to fail, which we never want to feel like, makes us feel like a terrible human. Here's what else can happen.
我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的恐怖下场。去听听《男友的女友们》。信我。在 iHeart Radio 客户端、Apple Podcasts 或任何你能取得播客的平台上收听。所以我们正在讨论职业嫉妒，是的，它会让人感到挫折，会让人感到非常恪慌和丑陋，它可能感觉像是秘密地希望某人失败，这是我们永远不想有的感受，会让我们觉得自己是个箜紕的人。这里还有可能发生的事。
I think the two most common manifestations of envy are disparagement and distancing, specifically in relation to our social relationships. You begin to resent your friends, you resent your colleagues even, and you act out in a bitter and annoyed way. Comparing to strangers is one thing, and I think the consequences of that are very isolated. They're very much individual for us. But comparing to peers, let alone close friends, is when we really start seeing interpersonal consequences. So I'm talking drama, tension, fighting, distancing between us and our friends.
我认为嫉妒最常见的两种表现是贬低和疏离，这在我们的社会交往中尤为明显。你会开始对朋友产生怨恨，甚至对同事也心生不满，并表现出一种痛苦和恼怒的情绪。与陌生人比较是一回事，而且我认为这种比较带来的后果是非常孤立的。它们对我们而言非常个人化。但与同龄人比较，更不用说亲密朋友了，这时我们才会真正开始看到人际关系的后果。所以我在谈论的是我们与朋友之间的戏剧性事件、紧张关系、争吵和疏离。
Honestly, though, you are. more likely to feel jealous of a friend than a stranger. It's why it is so common. So there was a 2015 study that found, yes, we are more likely to feel envy when the person we are comparing ourselves to is a similar age, the same gender, has similar values or even physical similarities to us, because it just gives more of a stark contrast to what we don't have. This person is a similar age, this person is our friend, this person maybe went to the same university, so much about our situations are similar. So what is it that we don't have in common that is setting our experiences apart? When someone is like us in many ways, it can further highlight what we are lacking
不过说实话，你确实比陌生人更容易嫉妒朋友。这就是为什么这种现象如此普遍。2015年的一项研究发现，当我们将自己与之进行比较的人年龄相仿、性别相同、价值观相似甚至外表与我们相似时，我们确实更容易感到嫉妒，因为这更鲜明地衬托出了我们所没有的东西。这个人年龄相仿，这个人是我们的朋友，这个人可能上了同一所大学，我们的许多处境都如此相似。那么，究竟是什么让我们截然不同呢？当某人在许多方面都和我们相似时，这会进一步凸显出我们所缺乏的东西。
and make us feel really terrible. I received this message from someone actually that I think describes this very, very well. She said, something I've been struggling with is my best friend and roommate recently landed her dream job and it's all she talks about. Rightfully so, but I'm struggling so much with my hatred of my current job. How could I be more enthusiastic? I honestly, I could have written this myself because I was once in your shoes. I literally was my best friend and my roommate got their dream job in the firm that I wanted a job in and I didn't get any bites. basically I was unemployed for the summer. And I'm going to admit it, I did entirely the wrong thing because I was so insecure.
并让我们感觉非常糟糕。实际上我收到过一条来自某人的信息，我认为这非常非常贴切地描述了这一点。她说，我一直在纠结的一件事是，我的闺蜜兼室友最近得到了她梦寐以求的工作，而她谈论的全都是这个。这本无可厚非，但我却极其痛恨自己目前的工作，内心充满了挣扎。我怎么才能表现得更热情一点呢？说实话，这话我自己都能写出来，因为我曾经也处在你这样的境地。我的闺蜜兼室友真的得到了她们梦寐以求的工作，就在我一直想进的那家公司里，而我却连一点回音都没有。基本上，我整个夏天都处于失业状态。我得承认，因为当时太没有安全感了，我做了完全错误的事。
I didn't want to talk to her about it. I shut her out. I distanced myself because her happiness, honestly, it made me feel bad about myself, not because I didn't want her to be happy, but because I wish that I could be happy with her. And the only way I saw that happening was if we were having the same experience. My biggest piece of advice in that situation and what I wish I had done, I wish I had just told her. I wish I had just said, hey, I am really trying to be happy for you.
我不想跟她谈论这件事。我把她关在门外。我疏远了自己，因为说实话，她的幸福让我觉得自己很失败，倒不是我不想让她幸福，而是因为我希望自己也能和她一样幸福。而我唯一能看到这种结果的方式，就是我们俩经历着相同的事情。我在那种情况下最大的建议，也是我希望自己当时能做的事，就是我真希望自己当时直接告诉她。我真希望自己当时说，嘿，我是真的很努力在为你感到高兴。
And I'm sure that if I was in your, if our roles were reversed, you would be so much better at this than I am. But just given how horrible I feel right now, I just can't be there with you. I just can't match this level of enthusiasm. So I really think we should just have some time. to talk about other things before we talk about work. Can we please talk about something that we have in common? Can we talk about something? Can we have more shared experiences so we can go off and talk about those things together? My other piece of advice is to be curious, to be open, to want to learn rather than judge yourself for what you don't have. And just addressing it
而且我敢肯定，如果换作我，如果我们互换角色，你一定会比我做得好得多。但鉴于我此刻感觉如此糟糕，我真的无法陪在你身边。我实在无法达到你这种热情的程度。所以我真的认为，在我们谈论工作之前，我们应该花点时间聊聊别的事情。我们能聊聊我们共同的话题吗？我们能聊点别的吗？我们能有更多共同的经历，这样我们就可以一起去谈论那些事情了吗？我的另一个建议是保持好奇，保持开放，想要去学习，而不是因为自己没有的东西而批判自己。并且在情况恶化之前
before you spiral is essential. You know, I always promote repair and honesty in these situations. it does feel more difficult, but it is 100% the path that you never regret. Because you will regret looking back in five years' time and saying, wow, that is my best friend. That was my best friend. I really cared about her. How come we don't speak anymore? Oh, oh, it's because I just didn't speak up and say something. Please, please take it from me.
着手解决它至关重要。你知道的，在这种情况下，我总是提倡修复和坦诚。这确实感觉更困难，但它绝对是你永远不会后悔的道路。因为当你五年后回首往事时，你会后悔并说道：“哇，那是我的最好朋友。那曾是我的最好朋友。我真的很在乎她。为什么我们现在不说话了呢？”哦，哦，那是因为我当时没有开口说点什么。请务必、务必听我的劝告。
Another unspoken consequence of career jealousy is that you end up losing motivation and you become quite discouraged. Jealousy is this weird thing where because we are only focusing on other people, we actually lose focus on our own performance and we start to neglect our own efforts to be better. Specifically, we start to focus on external factors for our lack of success and someone else's success. Typically, that comes down to things like fairness, things like luck, things that we can't control. So essentially what happens when we focus on. too much on what we don't have in comparison to someone else, is that we start shifting from an internal to an external locus of control. So this is a psychology term. Essentially, it refers to
职业嫉妒的另一个未曾言明的后果是，你最终会失去动力并变得相当沮丧。嫉妒是一种奇怪的东西，因为我们只把注意力放在别人身上，结果却失去了对自身表现的关注，并开始忽视自己变得更好的努力。具体来说，我们开始把缺乏成功以及别人的成功归咎于外部因素。通常情况下，这归结于诸如公平、运气等我们无法控制的事情。所以本质上，当我们过度关注与别人相比我们所没有的东西时，会发生什么呢？那就是我们的控制点开始从内部转移到外部。这是一个心理学术语。本质上，它指的是
how we view our problems and our ability to change an outcome or to change a situation. So an internal locus of control, you believe that you are the master of your own destiny, you are the guideer of your fate. There are actions that you can take to change what your life looks like and you feel willing to take them. An external locus of control is where you look at your circumstances and you put it all down to factors that you can't do anything about. So factors like luck, factors like fate, factors like, I don't know, status, money, where you were raised, you know, who you were born as. Those factors do play a role and I'm not going to deny it. But when we only focus on those, those are things we can't change. And so our circumstances is something that we can't change.
我们如何看待自己的问题以及我们改变结果或改变局势的能力。对于内部控制点，你相信自己是自己命运的主人，你是自己命运的掌舵者。你可以采取行动去改变你生活的模样，并且你愿意去采取这些行动。外部控制点则是指你审视自己的环境，并把一切归咎于你无能为力的因素。比如运气、命运、诸如我不知道的地位、金钱、你的成长环境、你投胎成了谁等因素。这些因素确实发挥了一定的作用，我不会否认这一点。但当我们只关注这些时，这些都是我们无法改变的。因此，我们的环境是我们无法改变的。
I need you to please stop focusing on the unfairness or the role of luck and start focusing on action. What can you do in this situation? I will say you are allowed to feel kind of bad every now and again. You are allowed to feel frustrated. Don't suppress those emotions entirely. But treat it as an indulgence, treat it as a treat rather than the whole meal. And when you realize that you have been stuck in a pity spiral for too long, I need you to turn around and say, Okay, we need to do more in the opposite direction.
我需要你们停止关注不公或运气的角色，转而专注于行动。在这种情况下你能做些什么？我要说的是，偶尔感觉有点糟糕是可以接受的。你感到沮丧是可以理解的。不要完全压抑这些情绪。但要把这当作一种纵容，把它当作一种小犒劳，而不是整顿大餐。当你意识到自己已经在自怜的漩涡中陷得太久时，我需要你转过身来说：“好了，我们需要朝着相反的方向做更多的事情。”
We need to do more towards our goal rather than towards despair. Okay, let's talk about how to handle and manage career jealousy. I had this weird epiphany at the gym the gym the gym. And at my gym, the treadmills are set up, so it's like two rows. So when you're on the treadmill, there is someone directly in front of you, or there is a treadmill directly in front of you, and there is someone probably running on that treadmill. during the busy times. And I was going not very fast. I was obviously, I'm recovering still in an
我们需要朝着我们的目标付出更多努力，而不是陷入绝望。好了，我们来谈谈如何处理和管理职业嫉妒。我在健身房有过一次奇怪的顿悟，在健身房里。在我的健身房里，跑步机是这样摆放的，分成两排。所以当你在跑步机上跑步时，你正前方有人，或者正前方有一台跑步机，在人多的时候，那台跑步机上可能正有人在跑步。当时我跑得并不快。很显然，我还在从
illness. And I was watching this girl in front of me. And oh my lord, she was quick. She was doing 11 kilometers an hour at like a 5% incline or like a 5.0 incline. And I was watching her and I was watching like the kilometers tick up and whatever. And I was like, oh my God, I need to catch her. I need to catch her. And I was like, wait, I'm on an entirely different treadmill. What am I going to go do? Run on her treadmill with her? Like, I can match her pace. I can do everything that she is doing.
一场大病中恢复。我看着我前面的这个女孩。天哪，她可真快。她以大约5%的坡度（或者说5.0的坡度）跑着每小时11公里的速度。我看着她，看着公里数一格一格往上涨，诸如此类。然后我心里想：“哦，天哪，我得追上她。我得追上她。”接着我想：“等等，我在一台完全不同的跑步机上。我要去干嘛？去和她一起在她的跑步机上跑吗？就像，我可以配合她的节奏。她做的一切我都能做。”
We are still running our own race. When you compare your career to someone else's career, you are comparing two people running on two different treadmills. There is no way that you can catch up with them. But you do need to focus on your own race. I don't know. I was just in that situation and I was like, wow. This has just made me rethink.
我们仍然在跑我们自己的赛道。当你把自己的职业生涯与别人的职业生涯进行比较时，你是在比较两个在不同跑步机上奔跑的人。你是不可能追上他们的。但你确实需要专注于你自己的赛道。我不知道。我当时恰好处于那种情境中，然后我想：“哇。这真是让我重新思考了。”
Every time I've tried to feel like I need to beat or best someone for whatever weird reason my brain is cooked up. I also want to remind you, and this is specifically advice for those of us in our 20s, which I'm assuming is a lot of you, you are comparing the very beginning of your race. You know, there are so many years to come. So many peaks and plateaus that everyone's career will naturally go through. No one's career is always going to be on the up and up. There will be times where they're not motivated, where you get made redundant, where the culture and the environment shifts. But what we're doing is we're looking at what, possibly only the first 10 years maximum of our career and thinking,
每当我试图觉得自己需要击败或超越某人时——无论我的大脑编造出什么奇怪的理由——我也想提醒你们，这特别是针对我们这些二十几岁的人的建议，我猜你们中有很多都是这样——你们是在比较你们赛跑的最开始阶段。你知道的，未来还有那么多年。每个人的职业生涯自然都会经历那么多的高峰和低谷。没有人的职业生涯会一帆风顺。总会有那么一些时候，你失去了动力，你被裁员了，文化和环境发生了转变。但我们所做的是，我们正看着可能仅仅是我们职业生涯前十年（最多前十年）的东西，然后认为：
this defines the entire race. This defines all of my circumstances from here. until I retire. That is totally not true. How someone's beginning looks is not always indicative of how their middle or their end will end up. Just think about Olympic races or sports games. Even then, like our career is a lot longer than a 200 metre sprint. It's a lot longer than a two-hour ballgame. Like it's for a lot of us, the majority of our lives. So there are going to be peaks and troughs what you are comparing right now is just the beginning. With all that being said, I do think it's almost impossible to will yourself out of feeling envy because it is quite a spontaneous emotion, right?
这决定了整场比赛。这决定了从现在直到我退休的所有境况。这完全不是真的。一个人开始时的样子并不总是预示着他中间或结尾会如何。想想奥运会比赛或体育赛事。即便如此，我们的职业生涯也比200米短跑要漫长得多。它比一场两小时的球赛要漫长得多。对我们许多人来说，它占据了我们生命的大部分时间。所以未来会有高潮和低谷，你现在所比较的仅仅是个话开头。话虽如此，我认为要想用意志力强行克制自己不去产生嫉妒几乎是不可能的，因为这是一种非常自发的情绪，对吧？
So it's not an emotion that we can call on and then get rid of at our will. It often comes when our guard is down. But I think to keep chronic and acute envy at bay, you have to accept the discomfort, but refuse to give in to the shame that often follows. I think to keep comparison, specifically professional comparison, from becoming self-defeating, I want you to really explore why it is that you feel so jealous. I want you to get curious about what has triggered this feeling for you. Now, at times, career jealousy is actually an asset because it can spur on admiration and therefore inspiration,
所以这不是一种我们可以随叫随到、随心所欲就能摆脱的情绪。它往往在我们放下防备时悄然降临。但我认为，为了将长期的和急性的嫉妒阻挡在外，你必须接受这种不适，但拒绝向随之而来的羞耻感妥协。我认为，为了防止比较——尤其是职业比较——变得具有自我毁灭性，我希望你真正去探索为什么你会感到如此嫉妒。我希望你对是什么触发了你这种感觉保持好奇。有时候，职业嫉妒实际上是一笔财富，因为除了嫉妒之外，它还能激发人们的赞赏，进而带来灵感。
alongside envy. Career jealousy is actually telling you something pretty important about what you want. If this person had a life that you didn't care about, if you didn't secretly want what they had, you would not be feeling jealous. You only feel jealous because you feel invested in that situation and the reason you feel invested or emotional about it is because it is something that you desire. And so in that way, our jealousy is a great way at providing us with direction. I heard someone say this the other day, and what they said was, if you're ever struggling to know what you want from life, if you're ever struggling with direction, ask yourself, whose life am I most jealous of?
职业嫉妒其实是在向你传达一些关于你真正想要什么的相当重要的信息。如果这个人过着你并不在乎的生活，如果你并非暗地里也想要他们所拥有的东西，你就不会感到嫉妒。你之所以会嫉妒，仅仅是因为你对那种处境投入了情感，而你之所以会对它产生投入或情绪波动，是因为那是你渴望的东西。从这个意义上说，我们的嫉妒是为我们提供方向的绝佳途径。前几天我听到有人说，他们说的是：如果你曾纠结于自己到底想要从生活中得到什么，如果你曾在方向上感到迷茫，问问自己：我最嫉妒谁的生活？
Isn't that so funny? Like, what is a painful emotion is actually a really important one because it can reveal all of these parts of you, all these things and these ambitions that you secretly have. So I want you to reframe jealousy as proof of what you want. And I also want you to reframe jealousy as proof that you can get there. Because the only reason you're feeling envious is because someone has done what you want to do. So they've done it. This is really essential because then what we have here is admiration and motivation rather than just jealousy. So once you have thought about the person that you are most jealous of, you now have to realize
这难道不很有趣吗？痛苦的情绪实际上却是一种非常重要的情绪，因为它可以揭示你身上的所有这些部分、你暗自拥有的所有这些事物和雄心壮志。所以我希望你将嫉妒重新定义为你想要什么的证明。我也希望你把嫉妒重新定义为你能够达成目标的证明。因为你之所以会感到嫉妒，仅仅是因为别人做到了你想做的事。所以他们做到了。这真的至关重要，因为这样一来，我们拥有的就是赞赏和动力，而不仅仅是嫉妒。所以，一旦你想到了那个你最嫉妒的人，你现在就必须意识到：
Actually, they are probably also going to be the person that I admire the most. Now, you can do a bit of a reverse psychological engineering exercise. What I mean by that is, I want you to get more curious about their life. What specific behaviors, habits, or strategies are they using? What are they doing that you are perhaps not that you can realistically apply to your own career? What path did they take? What knowledge do you think they have? What kind of wisdom? Essentially what I'm saying is, please, please, please lean in, move towards not away from those that you envy. Now, if you're
实际上，他们很可能也是你最崇拜的人。现在，你可以做一个逆向心理工程练习。我这话的意思是，我希望你对他们的生活保持更多的好奇。他们究竟运用了哪些具体的行为、习惯或策略？他们正在做什么而你可能没有做，从而你可以切实地应用到你自己的职业生涯中？他们走的是什么路径？你认为他们拥有什么知识？什么样的智慧？我本质上要说的是，请、请、请试着去融入，走向那些你嫉妒的人，而不是远离他们。现在，如果你
finding that particularly difficult, there's evidence that doing small favors for someone that you envy can actually make you like them more. So this is called the Ben Franklin effect. If someone's success is really almost hurting you emotionally. Ask them for advice. Ask them if you can get involved in their project. Ask them if you can study with them. Ask them to sit down for a coffee with you and shout them the coffee. Now this really flips our brain's perception. The people we envy, they're an ally, not a threat. Now to kind of focus on you, you know, a lot of this has been about what we can do to change our relationship to others. What can we do internally for ourselves? I want you to make a list of everything that you feel that you are proud of and that you are good at
发现这特别困难，有证据表明，为你嫉妒的人做一些小事实际上能让你更喜欢他们。这就是所谓的富兰克林效应。如果某个人的成功确实在情感上深深伤害了你。向他们征求建议。问问他们你是否可以参与他们的项目。问问他们你是否可以和他们一起学习。请他们坐下来跟你喝杯咖啡，并由你来请客。这真的会彻底颠覆我们大脑的认知。我们嫉妒的人是我们的盟友，而不是威胁。现在，为了把焦点放在你身上——你知道的，前面很大一部分内容都在讨论我们能做些什么来改变我们与他人的关系。我们能为自己内部做些什么？我希望你列出一份清单，写下所有让你感到自豪的、你擅长的、
that has nothing to do with your professional career or your job. I want you to work on focusing on the areas where you are excelling, even if externally and in an individualistic society, those things aren't as celebrated. So let's go through a couple. You know, maybe you're training for a long distance run. Maybe you go to the gym every single day. That's something that not a lot of people can say they do. Maybe you commit time to your hobbies.
并且与你的职业生涯或工作毫无关系的事情。我希望你致力于关注那些你表现优异的领域，即使在外部和一个个人主义的社会中，这些事情并不那么受到赞颂。让我们来看看几个例子。也许你正在为长跑训练。也许你每天都去健身房。那是很多人都做不到的事。也许你把时间奉献给了你的爱好。
I would be really, really proud if I read five pages before bed every night. Maybe you call your grandma more than the average person. I want you to feel proud of something and I want you to focus on your assets and what you are good at. There are so many important psychological studies that show feeling proud of yourself is endlessly correlated to high self-esteem and fewer feelings of jealousy. And the other part about self-pride is that it's often self-determined. Now, we're not talking about arrogance, we're talking about genuine pride in your accomplishment. That is something that if you find, every single one of us, every single one of us can find something that we deserve to be proud of.
如果我每天晚上睡觉前能读五页书，我会感到非常非常自豪。也许你比一般人更经常给奶奶打电话。我希望你能为某事感到自豪，我希望你关注自己的优势和擅长的领域。有那么多重要的心理学研究表明，对自己感到自豪与高自尊以及较少的嫉妒感有着无穷的关联。而自我自豪的另一部分在于，它通常是自我决定的。现在，我们谈论的不是傲慢，而是对你取得的成就的真正自豪。那是如果你去寻找——我们每个人，我们每个人都能找到一些值得我们为之自豪的事情。
Really, I think this whole idea of turning inward is so important here. Stop looking externally for proof that you're doing okay and start measuring your value by how fulfilled you feel, even if others don't see value in what you're doing. How happy you make others feel. How purposeful you are. How genuinely happy you can say your days are. The progress that you're making in your own small ways. Taking more time as well to figure out what you want.
真的，我认为这种向内探索的想法在这里非常重要。停止向外部寻求你过得不错的证明，开始用你的充实感来衡量你的价值，即使别人看不到你在做的事情的价值。看你带给别人的快乐有多大。看你有多么笃定目标。看你能说出自己的日子过得多么由衷快乐。看你在自己微小的方面取得的进步。花更多的时间去弄清楚自己真正想要什么，
want, taking more time to find the perfect job, or just to find some kind of path, that's also an asset for you because you are not tying yourself down or flinging yourself onto a moving train too early in your life with no way of getting off. So I do actually think that's really, really important. Sometimes we see these people and they're like wonderkins, right? Like they're 21, 22 doing these amazing, amazing things. There's a line from a song that says, I'm always terrified of elevators that rise too fast, they never last. And a lot of people who are in those situations will tell you that around the age of 30 or 35, they really have to battle some of the real existential questions about deeper personal meaning that you're probably managing right now.
花更多的时间去寻找完美的工作，或者只是寻找某种人生轨迹，这对你来说也是一种财富，因为你并没有在太早的人生阶段就把自己五花大绑，或者毫无退路地跳上一列开往未知远方的疾驰列车。所以其实我真的觉得这非常非常重要。有时我们会看到这样的人，他们就像是神童，对吧？比如他们21、22岁，却做着这些惊人无比的事情。有一句歌词是这样说的：“我总是害怕那些上升太快的电梯，它们从不持久。”很多处在那种境况中的人在30岁或35岁左右时会告诉你，他们不得不与一些关于更深层个人意义的真实存在主义问题作斗争，而你现在可能正在应对这些问题。
So my final tip is to engage in some kind of mental time travel. There's this brilliant study in psychological science that found imagining yourself 10 years into the future actually really helps reduce the intensity of current emotional struggles, jealousy, envy, frustration included. So I want you to ask yourself right now, will I care about this in 10 years? What advice would my future self give me about this moment? If everything works out well, if I focus on myself, what is the version of me in 10 years going to be most proud of me that I did? I think this really helps dampen the jealousy response, and it keeps you having that forward-focused vision for yourself. Okay, we're going to take a short break, but when we return, I'm going to talk some final reminders,
所以我的最后一个建议是进行某种心理时间旅行。心理科学杂志上有一项极其精彩的研究发现：想象自己十年后的样子，其实真的非常有助于降低当前情感挣扎的强度——包括嫉妒、眼红和沮丧。所以我现在要问你：十年后我还会介意这件事吗？关于当下这个时刻，未来的我会给我什么建议？如果一切顺利，如果我专注于自己，十年后的那个版本会为我做过的事感到最骄傲的是什么？我认为这真的有助于减弱嫉妒的反应，并能让你对自己的未来保持那种前瞻性的愿景。好了，我们要稍微休息一下，但当我们回来时，我会分享一些最后的提醒，
and also introduce you to some listener questions about this topic. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
并且还会向大家介绍一些听众关于这个话题的提问。请继续收听。2%。这就是当旁边还有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在怪异的现代社会中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，穿透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
我们曾坚信种子油生来就会引发炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字TWO%，在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得当黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了两下小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out. on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, literally.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个时刻，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近的一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·hill畅谈80年代的霹雳瘾（快克）。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊那个时期的毒品，对，是的，确实如此。
But just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
但为了让你们所有人都清楚。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把那句话补充完整。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人来说。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《The Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师吉尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person
特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们对某事进行追求时，我们会在追逐中陷得太深，以至于意识不到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算做够了。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯蒂·罗斯，因为你觉得在人世间当一个好人很重要，
while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions. bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in.
难道你当好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，老兄。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是去当一个好人。加入我吉尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《The Hard Way》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《The Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出其中存在着明显的矛盾。
And her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
和她的故事。这开启了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨，这里是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。有两条黄金法则
that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
是任何男人都应该遵循的。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这新一季的《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，想得美。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So my lovely listeners, this is a brand new segment of the show, the very first of its kind that I'm trialing out. And it's a little Q&A section. So what I was finding was that after, I was releasing episodes. A lot of you were saying, hey, you didn't talk about this and this is really what I needed advice on. And I thought, you know what? I think that we can bring this in.
请收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。所以我的可爱听众们，这是节目中一个全新的环节，也是我首次尝试同类型的板块。这是一个小型的问答环节。我发现的是，在节目发布之后，很多听众说：“嘿，你没有谈到这个，而这正是我需要建议的地方。”然后我想，你知道吗？我觉得我们可以引入这个板块。
I think that we can bring in some of your questions so that I can answer them right now, right here on the spot. Now, given that this is a new part of the episode, I really do want feedback. If all of you come back and say to me, hey, we actually hate this. It's going away. this is just as much your show as it is mine. But I just thought it would be fun to give it a go. I'm going to try it for the next four episodes. And after I've done it for four episodes, I'm going to ask you guys all again,
我觉得我们可以加入你们的一些问题，这样我就可以此时此刻在这里直接回答它们。鉴于这是节目的一个新部分，我确实非常需要反馈。如果你们所有人回来对我说：“嘿，我们其实讨厌这个。”那它就会取消。这档节目既是你们的，也是我的。但我只是觉得尝试一下会很有趣。我打算在接下来的四期节目中尝试它。在这四期节目结束之后，我会再次问大家：
what do you think, do you like it? And depending on what you say, will determine its future. So please provide all the feedback that you want. But let's get into the questions. Now, the first question I got was, how does career jealousy and anxiety arise in siblings and how do you manage it?
你们觉得怎么样，你们喜欢吗？根据你们的回答，将决定它的未来。所以请提供你们想要的任何反馈。但让我们进入正题。我收到的第一个问题是：兄弟姐妹之间是如何产生职业嫉妒和焦虑的，以及你该如何管理它？
Honestly, I think the career jealousy between siblings is a lot more common than you may think because there is of course innate familial comparison. There's also all these family archetypes that we tend to fall into, right? The golden child, the black sheep, the underachiever, the overachiever and they really contribute to this sense of needing to prove yourself particularly in comparison to a sibling. Now we also talked about how we compare ourselves to people who are most or more. similar to us, specifically friends. Well, let's talk about siblings for a second.
说实话，我认为兄弟姐妹之间的职业嫉妒比你想象的要普遍得多，因为其中自然存在着天生的家庭比较。我们往往也会陷入各种家庭原型中，对吧？金童、害群之马、不走运者、优异者，它们确实促成了这种需要证明自己的心态，尤其是在与兄弟姐妹进行比较时。现在，我们之前也讨论过，我们如何把自己与那些和我们最相似的人（尤其是朋友）进行比较。好吧，让我们花一会儿时间来聊聊兄弟姐妹。
Like, you share some of the very same genes. You often share parents. You share a childhood environment. So there's all those differences between you do feel particularly pronounced. Also, you know, I've seen so many situations where parents often, you know, it's terrible to say, but they do favor one child and they do really focus on their success. you see it a lot with child actors actually, child actresses or actors who their parents put so much into them and then the other children are kind of like, okay, well, what about me? Just because my goals
你们共享着某些完全相同的基因。你们通常共享父母。你们共享着童年环境。所以你们之间的那些差异确实会让人感觉格外鲜明。此外，你知道的，我见过很多这样的情况：父母经常——说这话虽然很残酷，但他们的确会偏爱某一个孩子，并且确实把重点放在那个孩子的成功上。其实你在童星身上经常能看到这一点，那些男童星或女童星，他们的父母在他们身上投入了那么多，然后其他孩子就会觉得：“好吧，那我呢？”仅仅因为我的目标
and my dreams are different and my success looks different based on the industry that we're in doesn't mean it's any less important. So I think those are the circumstances that we're kind of dealing with here, innate competition and families, archetypes that we tend to fall into or roles we fall into. What I really want you to do is realize that a win for them is your win as well. No matter how much you have been conditioned to see them as competition, seriously, is that mentality hurting or helping your relationship? Sibling relationships are, oh my God, so underrated. So underrated. They are so important. They are so special. They are the people who will hopefully be with you for so much of your life.
和梦想不同，并且基于我们所处的行业，我的成功看起来也不同，这并不意味着它就不那么重要了。所以我认为这就是我们在这里要处理的情况，家庭中天生的竞争，我们往往会陷入的原型或扮演的角色。我真正希望你做的是意识到，他们的胜利也是你的胜利。无论你被灌输了多少要将他们视为竞争对手的观念，说真的，这种心态究竟是在损害还是在帮助你们的关系？兄弟姐妹的关系，天哪，太被低估了。太被低估了。它们是如此重要。它们是如此特殊。他们是那些希望能在你生命的大部分时间里陪伴你的人。
And if you have been raised to be in competition, I think it does get to a point where you have to seriously look at each other and say, I don't want to be, have this relationship with you anymore. Like this is not helping us. So fight back against that natural instinct. Take interest in their life, invest mentally, invest your curiosity in their life. And also talk about it with them. You know, if you can't talk about your insecurities with your sibling,
如果你从小就被教育要去竞争，我想总会有一个时刻，你必须严肃地看着对方并说道：“我不想再跟你有这种关系了。这种关系对我们没有帮助。”所以要奋起反抗那种天生的本能。对他们的生活产生兴趣，进行精神上的投入，将你的好奇心投入到他们的生活中。并且也要和他们谈谈这件事。你知道的，如果你不能和你的兄弟姐妹谈论你的不安全感，
Who are you going to talk about it with? Oftentimes they are so forgiving, and I wouldn't be surprised if your eldest or youngest sibling who you naturally compare yourself with doesn't turn around and say, oh my God, I do the exact same thing, because this is how we've been raised. This is who we have been raised to be, competitors rather than friends. So that's my advice for that question. Our second question from another lovely listener, how to navigate the scarcity mindset in particular that can treat. contributes to career jealousy. So for those of you not familiar with this term, the scarcity mindset is basically, it's a commonative fallacy in which we believe that resources, including financial resources,
你还能跟谁去谈论呢？通常他们是如此宽容，而且如果那个你自然而然与之比较的年长或年幼的兄弟姐妹转过身来对你说：“天哪，我也做过完全一样的事，因为这就是我们被抚养长大的方式。这就是我们被培养成的样子，我们是竞争对手，而不是朋友。”这就是我对那个问题的建议。来自另一位可爱听众的第二个问题：如何应对可能导致职业嫉妒的稀缺心态？所以对于那些不熟悉这个词的人来说，稀缺心态基本上是一种常见谬误，在这种谬误中，我们认为资源——包括财务资源、
emotional resources, social resources, jobs are limited. And so we end up becoming preoccupied with what we lack rather than what we have. and we get into this mindset that there is not enough out there in this world for us to have what we want. I want to remind you here, success is not a finite resource that has an end. There's always room for another famous celebrity. There's always room for a new pop star. There is not only so much to go around. There is room for you.
情感资源、社会资源、工作岗位是有限的。因此，我们最终变得全神贯注于我们所缺乏的，而不是我们所拥有的，并陷入这样一种心态：这个世界上根本没有足够的资源让我们拥有自己想要的东西。我想在这里提醒大家，成功并不是一个有终点的有限资源。永远都有容纳另一个著名名人的空间。永远都有容纳新流行歌星的空间。资源绝不是只有那么一点点。这里有属于你的空间。
And I need you to know that. Otherwise, I do think you'll begin to see someone else's advancement as costing you your own. And so you're never able to have that real kinship and ally mentorship relationship with other people. And you'll get into this them versus me mindset, which, you know, I actually really understand. I've fallen into it a lot of times. It comes from this idea that what we want is lacking in the world and there's only room for a couple of people. You know, it's based on this mindset, of course, if I get the job, someone else loses theirs.
我需要你知道这一点。否则，我认为你确实会开始把别人的晋升视为以牺牲你自己的晋升为代价。因此，你永远无法与其他人建立真正的亲缘关系和盟友导师关系。你将陷入这种“他们对阵我”的心态，你知道的，其实我真的非常理解。我自己也曾多次陷入其中。这种心态源于这样一种观点：我们想要的东西在世界上是匮乏的，而且只有几个人的空间。你知道的，它当然基于这样一种心态：如果我得到了这份工作，别人就会失去他们的工作。
If my friend is successful, well, I can't be until they're not. It's very, very untrue. My biggest piece of advice is to work really hard to undo this mindset, keep applying for jobs, keep your options open, volunteer, search for opportunities in as many areas as you possibly can. And remember that your success, just because it's not happening right now, doesn't mean that it's never going to happen. your dream job, your dream career, your big break, it might not even exist yet, it might not even,
如果我的朋友成功了，嗯，那在他们失败之前我是无法成功的。这非常非常不真实。我最大的建议就是努力去纠正这种心态，继续申请工作，保持各种选择的开放性，去做志愿者，在尽可能多的领域寻找机会。并且要记住，你的成功，仅仅因为它现在还没有发生，并不意味着它永远不会发生。你梦想中的工作、你梦想中的职业、你的重大突破，可能现在还不存在，甚至可能
you know, all the dominoes may not even be aligned to bring it into existence yet. It doesn't mean that where you are now is where you will always be. There is definitely room for you at any table that you want to sit on, sit at, I guess, even if you need to carve that space out over time for yourself. All right, let's talk about this next question. Why does it feel like sometimes it's up to luck and not? not meritocracy. So meritocracy based on merit. It basically suggests that if you work hard enough, there is something that you should be entitled to. I'm going to tell you something that I think a lot of
所有的多米诺骨牌还没完全排好来让它成为现实。这并不意味着你现在所在的地方就是你永远停留的地方。在任何你想坐的餐桌旁，绝对都有属于你的位置——或者说座位，我想，即使你需要随着时间推移为自己开辟出那个空间。好了，我们来谈谈下一个问题。为什么有时候感觉一切都取决于运气，而不是任人唯贤？所以精英统治（任人唯贤）是基于才能的。它基本上表明，如果你足够努力工作，你就应该理应获得某种东西。我要告诉你们一件事，我认为很多人可能
people probably deserve to be told earlier. And I'm very sorry if it's upsetting, but really sometimes things are just up to luck. A small part of everything is luck. Right place, right time. they just happen to choose or make the right decision at the perfect moment when it worked out for them. I know it's really, really rough, but I feel like it's kind of unfair that we've all been sold this idea that, yes, if you work hard, there's something that you are innately deserving of. There's so many more factors at play. Here's the good news, though. Luck is not a finite thing, just like success.
更早就应该听到这些。如果这让人感到不安，我深表歉意，但实际上有时候事情确实只取决于运气。任何事情中都有一小部分属于运气成分。在对的时间，在对的地点。他们恰好在完美的那一刻做出了选择或正确的决定，于是事情就对他们奏效了。我知道这真的真的很残酷，但我觉得我们所有人都被灌输了这样一种观念——是的，如果你努力工作，你就能理所当然地获得某种东西——这其实挺不公平的。还有更多的因素在起作用。不过，好消息是。运气并不是一种有限的东西，就像成功一样。
There is actually heaps of luck to go around. and luck also turns. Luck is this tricky little thing where we are so, so focused on what it feels like to not have it, that actually when we are rewarded with it and when the luck does come our way, we kind of almost don't see it. We're only focused on the moments when it's not ours. Really, I always think about my, I think it was like my eighth grade math teacher. Her name was Miss Marianne.
实际上有大把的运气可供分享。而且运气也是会转变的。运气就是这样一个棘手的小东西，我们太过于、太过于关注没有运气时的感受，以至于当幸运降临、当运气真正向我们走来时，我们几乎都快看不见了。我们只关注那些不属于我们的时刻。真的，我总是想起我的，我想那是我的八年级数学老师。她的名字叫玛丽安老师。
I think Mary Ann something. And she always said, luck is when preparation meets opportunity. So you may not have the opportunity part yet, but you can work on the preparation part so that when everything aligns and it's your moment, you are there to take it. So our final listener question from the day is about the third type of career jealousy that we experience. If you remember, we have three categories. The third type is material jealousy.
我想是玛丽安什么的。她总是说：“运气是当准备遇到机会时发生的。”所以你可能还没有遇到机会那部分，但你可以致力于准备那部分，这样当一切对齐、轮到你的时刻到来时，你就在那里抓住它。所以我们今天的最后一个听众问题是关于我们经历的第三种职业嫉妒。如果你还记得的话，我们有三大类。第三种是物质嫉妒。
So this person says, my friends are paid four times more than me. I feel left out of their lavish lifestyles. What can I do? Let me just say that is rough. It's really rough when it feels like your friends are entering this entirely new financial chapter of their life and you are stuck in the past. What I really want you to do is to open communication with them. hopefully money hasn't changed their mindset and money hasn't changed their opinion on you i'm going to give them the benefit of the doubt and say that it hasn't and so i'm assuming they still very much love you
所以这个人说，我的朋友们的薪水比我高四倍。我感觉自己被排除在他们的奢华生活方式之外。我该怎么办？请允许我直言，这确实很残酷。当你觉得你的朋友们正在跨入他们人生中一个全新的财务篇章，而你却被困在过去时，这真的很难受。我真正希望你做的是与他们展开开诚布公的交流。希望金钱没有改变他们的心态，金钱也没有改变他们对你的看法——我愿意对他们抱持善意并认为没有改变，所以我假设他们依然非常爱你。
they desire your company they want your company i really want you to just discuss with them opportunities to do things that are less expensive and that um are more affordable and that maybe don't include four-course meals and don't include luxury spending but are simple honestly I feel like I've had conversations with friends like this before where I've been like hey like you know I can't come to your birthday dinner but I would love to do this smaller thing with you or someone said hey I can't afford to contribute to this gift or I can't afford to go on this trip but I want to still be involved in some way a good friend will be receptive of that I also I want to give you a really really strong piece of advice here
他们渴望你的陪伴，他们想要你的陪伴，我真的很希望你能和他们商量一些开销较小的事情，比如那些更实惠、可能不包含四道菜的大餐、不包含奢侈消费，但很简单的事情。说实话，我觉得我和朋友们也有过这样的对话，当时我会说：“嘿，你知道吗，我不能去你的生日晚餐，但我很乐意和你一起做一些小规模的事情”或者有人说：“嘿，我负担不起这份礼物的份子钱，或者我负担不起这次旅行的费用，但我仍然想以某种方式参与进来。”一个好朋友会接受这一点的。而且，我还想在这里给你一个非常非常强烈的建议：
please do not try and match their spending. I'm not a financial advisor, obviously, but I've seen people do this. I remember reading an article about someone who got into a significant amount of debt trying to keep up with their friends' lifestyle. If they are your friends, you don't need to impress them. And doing things just for appearances rather than meeting your actual needs and spending money where you feel its purpose is, is a very dangerous game to play
请千万不要试图迎合他们的消费水平。显然我不是理财顾问，但我见过有人这么做。我记得读过一篇文章，讲的是某人为了跟上朋友的生活方式而背上了巨额债务。如果他们是你的朋友，你不需要去印象他们。为了面子做事，而不是满足你的实际需求，把钱花在你觉得有意义的地方，这是一场非常危险的游戏
and I wouldn't want to see you get into debt or into trouble because you feel like you need to impress your friends. If they're the people who need to be impressed, they're probably not your friends. So obviously I don't have all the full information but I would really just say have a chat with them about it.
而且我不想看到你因为觉得自己需要给朋友留下好印象而陷入债务或麻烦。如果他们是那种需要被留下深刻印象的人，他们可能根本算不上你的朋友。所以显然我没有全部的信息，但我真的只想说，和他们聊聊这件事。
Don't excessively spend money and if you feel like their priorities have changed beyond, well, because of the money maybe start considering whether your priorities towards friendship should change as well. Okay, my lovely listeners, thank you for joining me for this new segment. As always, please let me know what you think of this. Also, what I'll be doing is I'll be putting up the questions three to four days in advance on Instagram. So if you want to get involved
不要过度花钱，如果你觉得他们的优先事项已经变了，嗯，可能是因为钱的关系，也许开始考虑你们对友谊的优先事项是否也应该改变。好了，我可爱的听众们，感谢你们加入我这个新的板块。一如既往，请告诉我你们对此的看法。此外，我会做的是，我会提前三到四天在Instagram上发布问题。所以如果你想参与
in these questions, you want to be able to contribute to episodes. Please follow me over there. It's at that psychology podcast. And also, I love hearing feedback. I love hearing episode suggestions from you all. We really do have such a beautiful community. So come on over, get involved. And if you're already there, well, say hello. I'll see you over there. Make sure that you were following along with the podcast so you know when new episodes go live and leave a five-star review if you feel called to do so.
在这些问题中，你希望能够为节目做出贡献。请关注我。账号是that psychology podcast。而且，我喜欢听取反馈。我喜欢听你们所有人的节目建议。我们真的拥有一个如此美好的社区。所以快来加入吧。如果你已经在那里了，那就打个招呼吧。我在那里等你。确保你一直在关注播客，这样你就知道新节目什么时候上线，如果你觉得有必要的话，请留下五星好评。
Or share this episode with a friend who feel like might be struggling with a lot of career jealousy. Trust me, a lot of us are in the same boat. This is a no shame zone. Hopefully you have been able to learn how to better navigate. get these feelings or at least reframe your thoughts towards your jealousy. As a reminder as we end this episode, please be safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself and we will talk very, very soon. On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. Eighty-four was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down,
或者把这集分享给一个你觉得可能正在与大量职业嫉妒作斗争的朋友。相信我，我们很多人都在同一条船上。这里是一个没有羞耻感的地带。希望你已经能够学会如何更好地应对这些感受，或者至少重新调整你对嫉妒的想法。作为本期节目的结束提醒，请注意安全，保持善良，对自己温和一点，我们很快就会再聊。在Look Back at it播客中。对1979年来说，对我来说那是一个大时刻。八四年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games.
并试图弄清楚我们是如何与朋友、同仁喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起度过难关的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。那是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯主持的“用困难的方式学习”。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在其他任何地方进行这些对话真的都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套或盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“用困难的方式学习”。2023年，“黄金单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Manchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这就是“被困的爱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“被困的爱”播客。2%。这就是走楼梯的人数比例。当还有自动扶梯可用的时候。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了心理坚韧的科学，
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the I-Heart Radio app,
体能，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听2%。也就是TWO%。在I-Heart Radio应用程序上，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends.
Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时。她们采取了行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是这么说，相信你的女朋友。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。